oh good morning Hank morning John it's
Wednesday I think we're in Westport
Connecticut we just got to the hotel and
we are unpacking all of the current
nerdfighter gifts including an
extra-large world's best grandma shirt
perfect size for John Green well I don't
know if you remember the book but in the
book it's too big so incensed that it
would be too big but thanks for pointing
out that I'm fat cows the great American
Gordon heard fighting music Eko geeking
and nerdfighting tanks passions Culver
Creek shirt Culver Creek preparatory
school from Looking for Alaska
just like Louis thank you Jeff sparks
for ten minutes it's two more steps
buddy isn't sick baby yeah someone got
us three whole catfish wrap separately
some v6 pack a mountain Dew a dozen
tulips a bottle of water a box of
tissues and a can of blue spray paint
Paper Towns - or eleven 1108 Oh peeps Oh
peeps peeps Oh peas it's in half yeah
Amish printer Fred Amish hunger Wonder
Bread Amish hunger Wonder Bread it looks
like this I'm gonna taste it mmm
Oh mushy puppy-sized elephant piggy bank
don't put too much of your money in
there it's just like the American
economy Oh empty
mr. kingdoms the crumbling towers in
your pants team zombie because I prefer
the hard truths of zombies to the easy
lives of unicorns besides no offense
rainbows it's all velcro so you can take
it off and put other stuff on - god I
love rainbows nerd duck reminds me of
Zay yeah it does definitely remind me of
they insisted I'm the chairman of
awesome
cheer chairman it's a special Christmas
ornament for Willy oh that's cute it's
Willy look nerdy's cereal men on the
backs of Shakespearean insults thou
mangled hedge borne Punk this person
says nerdy's is also a great thing to
put on your head I went to finishing
school
this that's what you learned in
finishing school I certainly didn't
learn how to dance because no one would
dance with me at Crown school for
dancing
the only semi-autobiographical thing in
Paper Towns
I love these scrunch scrunch that's not
a Fresnel lens it is that's awesome
really good for focusing sunlight on
ants also on solar panels oh right
that's very confusing okay well how do I
look
other than awesome I mean fun how see
Fred what voila Wow
that's where it is there never greater
you Walker company would recognize
how much off more awesome nerds would be
if they call them fight nerds oh it's a
go-fast bahar I'm gonna eat it oh I want
to eat it all right you can have some on
this hunger Wonder Bread it's delicious
too and look Hank it's bubbles the
nerdfighting puppy that's like an exact
replica of his cast he's a cute little
guy I miss you Willy
who's gonna pee on the floors in the
hotel room without you just me it all
falls to me I have to make the mess and
clean it up when you're around you can
do the peeing on the floor for me I do
this and then crazy when the stuff that
you imagine becomes real it is a very
gratifying
cows